[Music]
on today's show we got special guests
the minimalist
in the house we're going to talk about
trauma childhood
friendship relationships their new book
on loving people and not things
and i'm the second best looking guy they
talked to today
stay tuned
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john deloney's show
hope you're doing well thank you for
joining us
i've been out of town for a few days
james you've been out of town for a few
days
kelly of course is just staying here
slow and steady
somebody has to hold this thing together
here we go let's just talk about how
important kelly is
it's good to see you i've missed it
everybody i missed you nikki b
it's good to see you and i got some
special guests my friends are in the
booth jeff and tiffany it's good to see
them too
even though i can't see them because
they're over there but you know just
whatever
hey special show today this is awesome
we have two people who i love
i just i love them and uh joshua fields
milburn ryan nicodemus otherwise known
as the minimalist
they travel the world teaching people
a new way to live right a new way to
live
and it looks like um hey let's get rid
of your stuff man
so much more these guys are awesome
they've got a new book out and they are
here to talk about
their childhoods with me we talk about
trauma we talk about relationships
friendships we talk about a lot of stuff
we talk about the seagull effect
so good some of you have parents who are
seagulls and
you'll have to listen to the show to
know what that is is that can you that
can be right right
parents can be seagulls yeah just fly by
and
you don't give it away you got to just
tease it like what you just did there
that's
they actually called this part this part
this isn't the teaser this is the opener
right
it is technically but you can you can
have multiple teasers just
just so you know i asked that question
and james rolled his eyes like a
sad father like hey daddy is
did they run four bases in football and
you're just like
no no son it's they have touched he just
seagulled you
he did he did he seagulled me and if you
want to know what that is stay tuned
right here on the dr john dolonie show
all right so i'm here with the
minimalists on we are
if you're watching this on youtube we
are triple same side of the booth thing
this are you all same side of the booth
daters yeah
right were you yeah yeah yeah yeah i
still am well yeah i love sitting on the
same side of the booth
booth as my wife oh
i'm looking at your wife she confirmed
it she's like we do yeah i was about to
make a
joke and i'm super not going to i'm just
going to think that's really normal and
great and
i'm excited for you guys oh man
okay so thanks for listen there's
there's
a few times in my career
when someone just does me a solid this
is that right you'll have better things
to do with your time so i'm so grateful
you'll stop by to get out of here man
no thanks so great um can i see a
question before we get started
absolutely how does it feel to be the
second most
handsome radio personality at ramsay
who's the first
what it's ramsay right i thought it was
ken i
mean
[Laughter]
i gotta be careful because dave signs my
check
i'm at least tied with ken
it feels great when i drive home and i
think
man i tanked these phone calls someone
called in their marriage was on the
brink and i just
i tried to answer it but i ended up
shoving them off i look in the rearview
mirror i think but you are the second
best looking guy
here at least i'm toothsome
exactly um all right so tell us how you
guys got
got rolling here oh man the heck is a
minimal
it all started when we were born josh a
minimalist
as a minimalist everything i own serves
a purpose or brings me joy that's the
sort of stock answer but let's
really break it down to how did we get
here right
because ryan and i grew up really really
poor we're from dayton ohio right up the
street
and um right up i-75 and we had a lot of
sort of abuse in the house
drug abuse alcohol abuse physical abuse
and we thought the reason we're so
unhappy is because we didn't have a lot
of money
and of course well when we turned 18
went out and got corporate jobs climbed
the corporate ladder
for the next dozen years and found out
that maybe
money wasn't the key to happiness for us
either in fact it sort of amplified some
bad behaviors that we picked up when we
were
kids and so we started questioning
two things happened to me my mom died my
marriage ended both in the same month
and right as i was approaching age 30. i
was sort of at the pinnacle of this
corporate career i was managing 150
retail stores i was a director of
operations responsible for all these
employees all this real estate
and i realized there was something sort
of missing
it's the same thing was missing when i
was a kid though that sense of meaning
that sense of purpose
and i tried to get it the way many
people get it it's through
accumulation through stuff through
status through success through
achievement
and those things aren't working of
course i always thought happiness was
right around the next corner
and it never was and it was rather
elusive in fact
i think the pursuit of happiness is one
of our biggest problems it's even in our
founding documents it's in the fabric of
this country right it's in our area but
happiness can't be pursued it can only
be uncovered
whenever we try to pursue happiness
that's a type of chase
and and those chases always lead to some
sort of attachment
and those attachments always keep us
from being free
in a way and so i was very attached to
my stuff the average american household
has 300 000 items
in it and i was like that yeah i was a
bit of a hoarder a well-organized
hoarder so i had boxes and bins and all
of my stuff neatly labeled but i still
had a lot of stuff
it'd be great if all those things are
making us joyous and happy
but they're often the objects of our
discontent not the objects of our desire
when we get them when we get them
isn't it funny how we no longer want the
thing that we thought we wanted we're on
to the next
yes always the the next pursuit and it's
not about well the fact that i can't
appreciate the thing it's that
i'm being told that i'm not enough and i
felt that as a kid i wasn't enough
because we didn't have enough
but then i felt that as an adult because
a lot of our advertisers marketers
demographers statisticians they conspire
to make us feel inadequate
and of course they have the the product
or service the the solution to the
problem that they've created
and so i never really felt like i was
enough so i pursued
more in that pursuit of more
left me feeling empty and when my mom
died my marriage ended it made me look
around and start to question
all of that and realize like oh oh
the the stuff isn't the answer it is
actually the new
problem that i have so growing up in a
house of
you just sit between us for a while and
we'll get you in a bit i'm just here for
support
growing up in a house of poverty growing
up in a house of
addiction and or abuse all that trauma
and trauma and trauma
and then you fast forward through what
would i would imagine would be
a nightmare cocktail trauma
it you've made something remarkable take
us back to that
month what i mean well you know what's
fascinating is when i started
questioning it was about eight months
where i started
simplifying my life it was it was
holding up objects literally and saying
does this thing add value to my life and
realizing that
oh i was pretending everything was
precious
but if we say everything in our life is
precious well then nothing's precious if
everything's valuable then nothing by
definition can be
valuable to us right if everything has
equal value in my life then it's all
worthless and so i started questioning
these things and realizing like oh
i bought that as an aspirational
purchase maybe that
that sweatshirt look or that shirt or
whatever looked great on the mannequin
or i thought that i would be the type of
person
who was in that rolex ad if i just owned
a rolex
and not that there's anything inherently
wrong with the stuff ryan and i aren't
against stuff
we're not monastic if you want that
that's fine
but we're trying to figure out a better
way to live
in society without being of society as
one might say
right and so over the course of about
eight months i've radically simplified
my life i got rid of about 90
of my material possessions but
i was talking to dave about this earlier
the the thing about
letting go is letting go isn't something
you do it's something you stop doing
you stop clinging to the stuff you stop
clinging to the past
you stop clinging to toxic relationships
you stop
clinging to the material possessions you
thought were so
important but it doesn't mean you can't
hold on to the things that add value to
your life
so a lot of things do serve my life the
paradox of minimalism now is i get far
more value from the things i own
than i did 12 years ago when i had all
of these
excess things so in a way
and i'm trying to draw a link between
that that month
and so this this awakening this
realization
yeah i gotta let mom go i gotta let this
relationship go i gotta let the stuff go
yes and it all worked together right
in fact somebody stopped me in a parking
lot a few months ago and
said i need to call your show one day i
just can't do it yet my mom died and
i've got all her stuff in my house and
i've turned into a hoarder
and i looked at him just in the parking
lot said you got to let your mom go and
he started crying the parking lot right
but there's this moment something
triggered in you oh and then you bring
your friend along
like who who was a part of this journey
well who started the journey he started
it
um he was like dude get rid of
everything let's do this well we've been
friends since we were fat little fifth
graders
so i mean we've known each other forever
and
uh i was at a point in my corporate
career where
you know i was working 60 70 sometimes
80 hours a week
i was doing a lot of drugs i was
drinking a lot
i was chasing all the ephemeral things
it's funny because i think about that
kelly and we're looking at kelly she's
that's she's in this phase right now
kelly the drugs eventually stopped
working i've been trying to
be super glad there's a whole lot of
people in here right now
[Laughter]
uh but yeah i mean that stuff that does
stop working after a while
and you know he's talked about the the
chasing happiness and i did i
oh boy i chased happiness and i would
grab it every once in a while but as
soon as i had a hold of it it was like
fleeting it was gone so i just i got
tired of
living the way i was living and um yeah
josh came to me
and uh he said hey man you got a lot of
stuff you might
want to check out this minimalism thing
i mean really it was like this
conversation it started with me
uh because i noticed that he after you
know
his mom died and his marriage ended i
noticed he was living
a lot lighter a lot happier his attitude
had changed
like the firs the first thing i noticed
is he went to her boss and he was like
hey man i'm not answering my phone after
seven o'clock that was like sacrilegious
in the corporate world
like you answer your phone at 11 o'clock
if your boss calls you
so it was things like that and i'm like
what is going on with you man like why
the heck are you so happy he's like
you might want to check out this thing
called minimalism if it was anyone else
i don't know
if i would have dove into it the way i
did but uh i got really excited like he
kind of
just showed me a few people there's a
guy named colin wright he's a
peripatetic writer he was like traveling
from country to country
every three months he carried everything
he owned in his backpack
i didn't want to live that life but i
saw what he was using minimalism for and
then he showed me minimalist families
and
there was a gal named courtney carver
she lived in salt lake city she had a
family
husband and daughter there's a guy named
leo about to he had eight kids
he was living in san francisco so all
these people were living
deliberate meaningful lives and really
what i saw was common sense man and i
was just like oh like i need more common
sense in my life you know
but when you grow up in a house where
you don't have a picture of that and
then somebody gives you a picture of
what this looks like right
and that's why i think people have been
attracted to you guys oh you offer a
not just a cerebral or some kind of
cognitive like here's a couple of
thought like no here's a picture of what
this looks like
yeah and we are simply moving through
life lighter than you yeah
people come to it like moth to a flame
right it's funny you say that cause like
i remember the first time
where i thought i saw what happiness was
i used to work for my dad painting and
hanging wallpaper
and we were in this house and it was a
pretty modest house
um you know midwestern whatever like not
like we were in mansions that had
bowling alleys and indoor pools and i
never aspired to have anything like that
but we came across this really nice
probably five bedroom three bathroom
house
and the family looked really happy the
pictures on the wall the family looked
really happy and i'm like dad how much
do i need to make to own a house like
this because it was something nicer than
like he or my mom had ever owned
he's like son if you can make fifty
thousand dollars a year so this is like
you know 94.
it's just a million dollars right
exactly if you can make 50 000
a year you could probably own a house
like this so that was my number
and then you know i eventually made 50
000 in the corporate world
and i'm like well wait a minute i'm not
happy maybe it's 65 000 maybe it's 90
000 maybe it's owning a bunch of stuff
so
yeah i was just like chasing chasing
chasing um
when i got excited about the idea of
minimalism i was just i just looked at
josh i'm like all right yeah dude i'm in
i'm a minimalist like now what do i do
like a stork drops or an owl comes by
and drops it like a certificate
yes yeah that's fantastic so we came up
with this idea called a packing party
where we decided to pack up all my
belongings as if i were moving
and then i would unpack only the items i
needed over the next three weeks
so like josh came over and literally
helped me box up everything
clothes catch and wear towels furniture
toiletries picture frames
photos even my furniture like we covered
it up
so over the next three weeks i just
unpacked things as i needed it
toothbrush
bed and bed sheets clothes for work the
furniture i actually use a tool set just
the things that were adding value to my
life
and after that experiment i had 80
percent of my stuff
like still sitting in boxes and that was
like the huge
revelation moment of like like yeah like
first off here all these things i
brought into my life to make me happy
and they're obviously not doing their
job
like i'm not i'm not happy and i'm not
using these things
and then i started thinking about like
oh man
my priorities were really screwed up
like if you would have asked me before
that packing party
hey ryan what are your priorities i
would have gave some really good answers
like my health you got to be healthy
you know you gotta have really good
relationships you gotta be grounded you
gotta you know
contribute beyond yourself in a
meaningful way and then i just looked at
like
how i was really just giving a lot of
lip service to my priorities because all
that stuff that was packed up that's
what my priorities were it was
accumulating all that stuff so
i decided to get rid of it donated it
sold it recycled it
that's really where the minimalists.com
started it was with that 21-day packing
party story
yeah so back me up what is um
brothers sisters parents yeah
what did you go first what'd your folks
do growing up yeah sure a lot of drugs
and alcohol yeah
yeah not that we're still hanging on but
it's cool yeah
oh man yeah my very first memory my
father was um
brilliant but he was schizophrenic okay
and um so my very
he started having right around the time
i was two or three he started having
really elaborate relationships with
people who didn't exist
in the real world he was a medical
doctor and so
i thought that yeah you would if you
paint the picture of when i was born in
1981
you would see like this well-off upper
middle class
maybe even upper class family in dayton
ohio
and then very quickly he got sick and
everything changed
my very first memory i was three years
old my father extinguished a cigarette
on mother's chest
and we escaped about a year after that
and sort of
moved to a suburb of dayton which also
sounds really nice but
it was not it was sort of the opposite
of nice in fact in our last film
uh which is on netflix we went back to
my childhood home there
and it's all boarded up and there were
like squatters living in it
and and i realized like we
we actually didn't have enough people
often come up to us they're like oh yeah
i was a minimalist growing up i was poor
it's like well yeah i was poor growing
up too and we certainly weren't
minimalists we actually could have
benefited from being more deliberate
with the
few resources we had right because
we didn't have a whole lot but but we
were sort of reckless with those
resources and then of course when i got
more money in my 20s
i continued the same habits money turned
out to be
an amplifier of those magnifying glass
yeah absolutely and so i made really
good money in the corporate world but i
spent even better money oh yeah so i had
heaps of debt i was actually
less well-off it's funny when i left the
corporate world
i was making a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year in dayton ohio which is
amazing i took a 90 pay cut when i
walked away from the corporate world
back in 2011.
made 23 000 that year and i was more
financially secure that year
because for the first time in my life i
was living within my means
and i was my habits
my actions matched my values for the
first time
not just the lip service values that
ryan was talking about earlier though
the priorities but my priorities
were actually in align alignment with
what i was doing
every day so i i talked to i talked
behind closed doors with people for
a long time years and years and years
and
someone in your situation whose mom
essentially rescued him as a young kid
you have brothers and sisters i have one
brother okay got
people out and then she
passes away that can be an untethering
moment for people
what kept that from being an untethering
moment for you well depends what you
mean by untethering right
so when i think of tethers i think of
that as a metaphor
for keeping me bound to something and
not being free
ah so it was a freedom moment yeah in a
way not not because of her but
because of what happened i think one of
two things could have happened whenever
there's a sort of
car crash like that you can either
course correct
or you can use that car crash to careen
into something else
right and then it turns into this this
terrible accident
um so when my mom died i went down to
florida she had
when she she moved down there right
before she passed like a few months
before she
found that she had stage four lung
cancer she had moved down there to
finally retire
right and so she spent her last days in
st petersburg florida
living off social security and and i
went down there one last time after she
passed and this time was to deal with
her stuff
and she had she wasn't a hoarder but she
had 65 years worth of accumulations
right
she had stuff and it was all crammed
into this one-bedroom apartment
old antique furniture and it wasn't junk
it was things she'd accumulated she
really found value in
but the things that are sentimental to
her i could
add sentiment to them and make them
sentimental to me
but i realized in that moment before the
whole minimalism thing it was in fact it
was my first sort of
dipping my toe into the waters of
minimalism
i had to deal with her stuff so i looked
at all these things and i did what any
good son would do i rented a giant
u-haul
in fact i had to wait an extra day to
get that foot u-haul right
i was just gonna bring it all back to
ohio now i already had my own house with
a full basement full of stuff an attic
full of stuff bedrooms full of stuff
so i couldn't co-mingle mom's stuff with
my stuff and so
i rented a big storage locker to just
keep all of her things like a mausoleum
of stuff
yes that's a great way to phrase that
and
and then i was looking through these
things and i i had a few sort of
realizations as i was going through the
things the first one was that
i was holding on to it because i was
holding on to her memories
and i saw i found these four boxes under
her bed it was my old elementary school
paperwork grades one through four
and i realized oh she was holding on to
the memories of me
then i also realized like wait these
boxes have moved from house to house to
house and they've been sealed for
decades no one's ever opened them yes
never and so the memories aren't in our
things
the memories are inside us and that was
like the first big aha moment as i was
going through those
things and then i looked around all over
all of her things and i said oh wait a
minute
i'm getting ready to do the same thing
except instead of storing her things in
a box under my bed
i was going to cram it all into this big
box with a padlock on it
a storage logger and then pay hundreds
of dollars every month to keep things
what just in case the three most
dangerous words in the english language
those three words justify us holding on
to so many things that are actually
getting in the way of our contentment
and so i called up u-haul and i
cancelled the truck
and then i um i called and i canceled
the storage locker
i spent the next 12 days selling or
donating almost everything not
everything but almost
everything and and i learned some other
lessons along the way
one was about sentimental items because
if i would have kept thousands of
sentimental items well
that's sort of like watering down the
sentiment in a way but by keeping just a
handful of sentimental items i was able
to get far more value from those few
things i kept
than if they were all just crammed into
that giant storage lab
i was so happy when i got that phone
call because i was supposed to go down
there and help him move all that stuff
that's the worst thing about having
friends is the move there's
nothing worse i'd rather my friend call
and say hey man
um my house is on fire i'll help you
but it's hey man uh can you help me move
nope
i had somebody ask me one time i was
like i will pay for half of the moving
company to move your stuff actually two
buddies
that's how i will help you like they
they were gonna show up to my house on a
saturday morning to move and a truck
rolled up and they said i bought an hour
and he bought an
hour we're not lifting we're not doing
that but yeah
so tell me about your growing up oh man
um
yeah so i yeah i had a lot of uh drug
abuse
uh physical abuse um my mom and dad
split up when i was in the second grade
uh my dad was a very strict very
hardcore jehovah's witness
so i grew up kind of in that religion i
lived with him most of my childhood
um my mom uh he got married had a kid my
mom got married had four kids
so i've got five half brothers and
sisters
um yeah i mean yeah step dad was
uh yeah he yeah he used to be the crap
out of me for sure
um but you know it's uh at 40 years old
oh man i've been through so much therapy
and you know different work like
letting go of the trauma and stuff and
uh i feel i feel like i have been able
to let go
of a lot of that um even with my mom
like my dad doesn't talk to me right now
because i'm not a jehovah's witness and
i've kind of like
yes spoken out against like hey man
which i thought i was going to be like
oh dad here's why you shouldn't be a
jehovah's witness and he was like i'm
not talking to you anymore
i'm like oh i should probably shouldn't
have done that um
and then uh my my mom her and i are
actually
really doing a good job of like
rekindling our relationship
and uh you know forgiving each other for
because i guess we both probably put
each other through some trauma like
as a child i used to think like oh i'm
not responsible for putting her through
trauma and maybe i'm not but
her the stuff that comes up is still
those are her battles so like i gotta
respect the stuff that comes up for her
so
she's actually coming out to uh visit um
like in a week or so
with my little niece um yeah so my
brothers and sisters i have one sister
uh
from my dad like i said half sister
she's doing awesome she like started her
own like social media company she's
doing great
then i've got like i've got a brother in
prison right now
um i got another brother and kind of he
hasn't been to jail in a while
but he's you know kind of he was in and
out i got a sister in like a in rehab
right now
um and then i have another sister who
she's doing pretty good she's got a
couple kids like found a good guy
uh so there's just a lot on my mom's
side there's a lot of
i don't know angst i don't know what to
call it you know just drama yeah just
drama that's going on yeah
swat team kicked in his door in the
eighth grade yeah yeah true story
true story yeah um that's sort of like
that's the that
that's the opening scene to some to like
the movie about
your childhood trauma it feels like is
the swat team kicking in your
front door yeah oh yeah yeah so one of
one of the
misconceptions i think of folks who
look and say if i could and i think
that's that
that pursuit of happiness that phrase if
i could just i think that's a
damaging sentence if i could just fill
in the blank once you get past
have a place to sleep it's a food yeah
some relationships basically if i could
just
is man if i was able to write a book
get an audience get a thing get a thing
then
slate gets wiped clean for me
everything's easy
beautiful spouses show up and just want
to marry you right
what i love i mean i appreciate your
vulnerability and honesty here is
there's human stories behind all this
stuff and those human stories show up
in random places at weird times and
still got two moms coming in a week yeah
exhale right and here we're gonna i'm
gonna be intentional about how right
and that backs me i before this
conversation
i had wrapped my head around minimalism
as a
way of being with stuff it's not it's a
it has to do with an approach to how you
walk through
life yeah right because some of the
things you're saying about
getting rid of i hear that when people
call the show when they're talking about
a toxic spouse or a toxic store you've
been telling yourself your whole life or
parents who
fill in the blank have their own version
of the way you should be living or
whatever that looks like
and the ethos sounds like it works
they're the same right it's just an
approach to earth yeah
i mean stuff is it's the initial bite of
the apple like
all that physical stuff is just it's a
physical manifestation of what's going
on in here
so once you get rid of that at least for
me when i got rid of that
outward stuff and i know it's worked for
millions of other people but
you start to make room to work with that
spiritual clutter the mental clutter all
that internal stuff that's going on you
can start to examine
not just like why am i bringing you know
why am i bringing this book into my life
it's you know why am i bringing this
relationship into my life why am i
bringing this job into my life again
yeah and again right yeah why am i
bringing in this pursuit into my life
so um yeah it's it's it is uh it's
interesting how minimalism
uh yeah it's kind of the the stuff is
kind of the trojan horse
yeah that's where it starts but it does
go so much deeper so what makes are
y'all parents
yeah you have kids yeah i've got an
eight-year-old eight-year-old okay
so what are you doing different what
makes you what makes you a good dad
i think i think kids are so much wiser
than their parents
and i don't mean like earned knowledge
over the years and
that's something that's different but
it's funny i her school teaches her
mindfulness
which is hilarious because who's more
mindful than a child
and what that really tells me is the
school spends 6 hours and 45 minutes a
day making her
not mindful and then they they try to
say well now we're going to get back
into our
minds so to speak but who is more
intentional who's more in the moment who
is more
present than a child and so i think
as a parent i have so much to learn from
my daughter like how to be human in a
way because
i've unlearned that humanity over the
last
40 years or whatever and it's been
acculturated
out of me right especially through the
pursuit of the things you know the thing
you want is never the thing you want
yeah you think you want i had a lexus
and that didn't do it for me so i bought
a second lexus
so now i have lexi and and two car
payments
and you know whatever it is a 72 month
loan and all of these
these things and it's like oh but what
did i actually want there
oh i wanted status i wanted significance
hmm that's fascinating you think you're
going to get significance from a shiny
car i'm a depreciating asset yeah right
how weird is that right well why do i
think that well because i've been told
that
i've seen other people who i believe to
be significant
and that's not to say there's anything
wrong with the car i own a car now right
there's not even anything wrong with a
lexus i'm sure they make
wonderful cars the problem is thinking
that is the
the thing is
yeah and so the thing i've learned from
ella is my daughter is is that
we're so far away from the moment all
the time we're clinging to the past
right
where we're clinging to some
hypothetical non-existent
future right and we're
so far away from right here right now
one of the things i recommend to parents
all the time is to touch your kid's face
and there's a lot of
physiology about kids and nerve endings
in their face
but what often that's a trick for me to
get parents to put their phones down
and get eye level with their kid and
be present with their kid right it's a
it's a
it's a both hand right but there's
something about that presence right yeah
um can i start touching your face josh
that's what this show's for and uh you
didn't know this was coming josh
so you know he's gonna be your guy i'll
start doing that with my wife i'll just
start touching it yeah
uh i love it what's one thing your kid's
gonna learn from you
yeah i well my friend rob bell says that
that kids are always learning from you
and sometimes it's from your words
they watch you that's right yeah and so
it's fascinating i remember when she was
really young and i would you know
tell her it's like make sure you use
your fork and then all of a sudden three
seconds later she
sees me pull a piece of broccoli off her
mom's plate and popping on that
and of course it's like oh i'm telling
you to do one thing and it's i've become
a parody of the parent where it's like
do as i say not as i do right and so
i think what she'll learn from me is
well it's the title of the book really i
mean it's love people use things right
for the longest time
i've used people and loved things
and we have a language problem you know
i can say that i love you john but i
also
love tacos right and we
one thing means like extreme like i
think most of us we don't really
understand love not even a little bit no
to love someone is to see them
who they are without trying to change
them right
and and so if ella learns anything from
me
he's her own human being she's not me
it's not me trying to force her into
anything although any
anytime i do because i feel like i
always know what is best
sometimes i do boundaries are important
for an eight-year-old
of course sometimes we can erect these
unnecessary boundaries
never been to someone's house and they
just have too many walls in it yes
they're like well wait a minute what
we decided to put a wall here and then
one right there as well
i think so frequently with our kids and
with our relationships
opening up all of these barriers
[Music]
for this imaginary catastrophic ending
more than like that's right yeah and if
it does
those walls aren't going to stop it
anyway right so yeah all right hey let's
take a quick break right here on the dr
john dolone show
[Music]
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt
i've been helping folks 101 for years
but i wanted to create something that
everyone could use anywhere at any time
so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just
walking with you through your anxiety
alarms from start
to finish i'll guide you through a
breathing exercise and show you how to
lean in
listen and head towards healing it is
free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
y'all been for instance fifth grade yeah
i've got uh
i consider that one of life's greatest
wins
amen so i've got three or four buddies
four of them
since we're zero same street we still
run together wow
the chances of us being able to own to
work together
zero right what drive so
i'm just going to drive some wedges
that's my goal what drives you crazy
about each other how do you still work
together ready
five years later how do we work together
no we are
oh man we're exact opposites so there's
something with
this symbiotic thing that we have going
on and it's funny because like
our whole lives not just with the
minimalist stuff but like we have been
each other's mentors and mentees
so like we've always looked up to each
other and it's we got really lucky
because you think about
how many people do you have proximity to
i mean it's a lot of people but
you're kind of limited so you don't have
a you know the billions of people in the
world you're limited to these people by
proximity so the fact that
him and i met each other out of
proximity
and have been able to work so well
together i mean no you're abs it's a
special thing you'll have relational
work that you have to do
or do you know like this weekend my
family and i we went camping with
another
family that we know and love and
there was one morning i woke up i had
not slept well and i grabbed a book and
literally headed to the woods and this
family knew me enough to not follow
yeah right of course they just that's
just john b
he will call me up every once in a while
i mean he hasn't done this in a while
but
especially when he was going through a
lot of his trauma he's like hey man um
i don't want you to call me for a week
just leave me alone and i'm like okay
you don't take it personal i'm gonna try
to jump in and solve it
and then like uh this girl that he was
seeing like she calls me up she's like
josh told me to not call him for a week
what is going on i'm like
that's that's josh like he's home yeah
he's in it he's just asking for some
support some space she's like i mean i
understand you're his best friend but
i'm his girlfriend
i'm like well this isn't gonna last long
and it didn't
here's a fun game you should just break
up now right yeah
no uh i mean we you know certainly you
know what it is we're open and honest
with each other and we
never we don't try to shame one another
if we have a problem with one another
like we
we're very honest about it very open
about it um that's that means we're not
trying to humiliate each other the
greatest friend trade i've ever heard
if if everybody in the world had the
courage
or the strength to call somebody that
they love and say i need you to not call
me for a week
and that person could hear it and go
great i'll see you on sunday
yeah instead we tell ourselves a
narrative about what does that say about
me
it's yeah it's all about what is this oh
i can't solve it i can't fix it
my wife goes to and we're we're both big
counseling proponents
there's the rare moment when she's like
yeah i'm working through this i don't
talk about with you yet but i'm gonna
talk about it
and i think oh cause i'm not right
immediately
make it about me right but the fact that
you do that and you can hear that is
such a great
model for friendship i've never thought
of it this way but when he asked me to
do stuff like that
it's actually an opportunity for me to
like
support him and i like to be a
supportive person in fact if you look
like on the enneagram like i'm the
helper
yeah so like for me to go out of my way
to support him like i look at it as an
opportunity to be like oh i can help
josh this is what he's asking for i
don't have to figure out what he wants
he's telling me what he's so clear
and how often do we jump in and go no
what you really need is to come over to
my house and have a bottle of wine and
some
and some pasta and we'll we'll salt man
what a gift yeah well it's
it's us trying to fix each other right
and and there is no fix right there's so
fit yes as soon as something becomes
fixed the only constant is change so you
can't
literally can't fix something and
i think the other thing we do two other
things really well and it took a while
to get there especially for me i think
it took me way longer to get here than
ryan
we don't try to change each other and we
don't try to convince each other of
anything
that last one by far persuading is
unloving
and um and so it's i don't have advice
for ryan
i don't have um tips for ryan i don't
have best practices
i just love ryan there are no shoulds
okay there are kids
yep but there are no shoulds there's
nothing he's supposed to do
the only way to love him to love anyone
is to not try to change them
is there a so i feel the pressure i'll
use something simple like
tipping right now we're in a world i i
over tip it's it's a it i could make it
a really
like oh man what a great guy he really
it's a it's a self-esteem issue right
like
i over tip too i need to make sure that
this person knows remembers me that i
was a cool
customer that day right and i want
because uh but i can make it altruistic
really
sure sure um but i also know now if i
don't
now it's just someone's gonna take a
picture of it and post it right
you is there any i don't know man
i'm new to this universe and so the
language is gonna be limiting but
is there brand limitations that y'all
have boxed yourselves into
brand limitations yeah it's weird i was
it's like dave getting dave ramsey
getting a credit card he can't oh
right you can't lease a car sure sure
the credit card thing is because that's
a limitation he set up for himself
right and if his values were to change
around that
and he he could find a way to articulate
that i don't think it ever would it
doesn't make sense for that i mean it's
an absurd
example i'll give you an example though
ryan and i um
we needed new computers recently so ryan
ordered it from the apple store
the one that was close to my house is in
like this giant shopping mall
and i get anxiety going in into shopping
malls but
i go in there and of course seven people
run across me uh what is the minimalist
guy doing in the shopping mall right
it's like oh i'm just buying something
product from a major corporation and
and so in a way it has it keeps me in
check as well because
it doesn't yeah it at first it's like
well
i i do care what someone else thinks
about me that's a that's a self-esteem
issue right
but really it's like okay are my actions
still aligned with my values because
even though ryan and i are radically
different in terms of personality we're
different on the enneagram we're
different on the myers-briggs stuff like
the
exact opposites of myers-briggs but
we have the same values we just have
different paths by which to get to those
values
dave and i talk about that a lot we have
very different beliefs but we have
very similar values and in fact that's
why i love reading that's why i love
hanging out with cool interesting people
because
i'm my goal is to change my beliefs
often as i grow up like get new
information learn new things
but i want to keep those tethered to
true values doesn't sound like you're
scared of accountability
and we live in a culture that is
terrified oh yeah
accountability becomes judgment and it
becomes oppressive
i personally need accountability because
i've proven to myself over time i can't
always
walk through life by myself why do we
have problems with it do you think
um i don't know yeah i'm scared to be
called out
there's shame there may be a shame yeah
well it's i think
we could probably do a whole show on
that i think we
are we are our wiring is i haven't used
machine metaphors but
we are co-regulated with other people to
know where we are
in relationship with other people and i
think
when someone holds us accountable
instead of choosing to hear that as a
way to bring us closer together
it's weaponized see i've already
accepted the fact that i'm a hypocrite
okay i mean we're all hypocrites yeah so
i mean it's it's just
what level of hypocrite are you okay um
i hate slave labor
yeah but i sure love my smartphone ah i
don't love it but i really enjoy it i
use it
uh my laptop you know i mean like i
really care about the environment
but man there's a lot of cobalt that's
in my life so i mean
there's there's a little bit of uh what
they call it call it cognitive
dissonance
yes that we all have to live with um
so yeah as we bend the arc towards what
does it look like right yeah
and then if someone calls me out on
something you know i can look in the
mirror and say
is there a valid point here or
uh is this person just being a seagull
and so here's
like there's a difference between
criticism and feedback criticism
it's called the seagull effect someone
flies in they like crap on what you do
and then they fly away
dude i love that yeah you're like oh
thanks
and then feedback is like it's it's the
problem presented with a solution
and okay so if i can differ
differentiate from those two
if someone's trying to hold me
accountable i can you know look at like
is this just criticism or is this
feedback and is it something i
legitimately
need to look at you all have to get
bombarded oh dude
with people deciding their version of
whatever their thing is and
how do you keep your guys insulated how
do y'all stay insulated from that
well i don't read the comments okay
pretty much
yeah it goes back to that should thing
right people
we we've moralized everything in our
culture can i believe in morality but
when it's like
hey you should go to college or you
should own a home at this
age or you should do this you shouldn't
do you should eat that
you shouldn't do that and it's like well
wait a minute
these things right and wrong in most of
these instances they're highly
individual
right because it's about preferences
it's about our own
values and if you have different values
from me then your shoulds are going to
be different than mine
and so there are no universal shoulds in
most of these things that we're talking
about and so yeah if someone else is
sort of heaping their own
values on to me i think at this point
it's fairly easy to dismiss that yeah
yeah the people who love you
let me say it this way who do you have
who have you given permission to speak
into
hold you accountable oh um i i
i will let anyone hold me accountable
again okay yeah like i don't
i don't there's no one i wouldn't
like just listen to it like if they came
to me they're like ryan so family or
friends like
social media is a different world yeah
yeah but like family and friends i mean
anyone can come to me and
say they have a problem with something
and i have um man i'll tell you when you
call yourselves the minimalists you find
out
very quickly who your real friends are
it's it's really
it was really crazy because yeah you
have all this judgment
you're not a minimalist ryan you
snowboard you know i mean she's like all
this stuff
so yeah um but because you know those
are exactly the same thing
and i don't know i don't know what has
given me this mechanism to
just hold space for other people's
judgments um
but it's just well the first couple
years we did this
it was very difficult like it was um i
just had i guess i've just developed
fixed in
skin over the last you know eight nine
years to where
uh yeah i just i don't let it ruin my
day anymore criticism
only hurts if if uh praise feels good
say that again if you need the praise
then the criticism will hurt more
okay if you don't need the praise
then the criticism if you then you don't
care and it's just information it is
right and so
and then it's less about the
accountability thing in terms of
accountability i often think of the
people i seek out like we have
some great people on our team you met
podcast sean and jordan
yeah we got jess and we got some new
folks who
are starting this month and so we've got
a nice core team
and seeking some sort of accountability
from them or feedback is a way to keep
myself accountable as well i may not
always agree with them
and that's okay but i can at least see
their perspective
so from from using the minimalist ethos
here
i had a season where i took everybody's
if you had an opinion i was willing to
hear it and if you had a reflection for
me i was
okay let's take it um and especially i
was working in university it was every
student every student's parent
every student's every cultural everybody
had an opinion about how i was doing my
job
and i tried to take them all and it came
ultimately i had to say well i've got to
pare this down too
there's about five or about six people
who i'm gonna get permission
to hurt me i'm gonna give five or six
people permission to
have access to my heart and those are
i'll take your criticism i'll take your
you know hey you need to do this better
you're not very good on this show you
should have done like i'll take that all
day but a
moral character judgment a you're not
being the person that you said you want
to be
i'm going to take that for fewer people
and it sounds like you're you seek that
out
like we've got a team that you all hire
intentionally or you surround yourself
with
say we're going to listen to them i
think i think when your actions are
in alignment with your values like
for me uh i don't like nothing i can
look in the mirror like no matter what
anyone says i can look in the mirror and
be like dude
i really like you yeah you know that to
me
that's that is yeah that's it right
yeah so you can look in the mirror and
say i like you and if anyone can help me
like myself better then i'm all ears
yes you know but beautiful anything else
that comes my way it's just like
i like i've worked so hard over these
last ten years so like really i'm not
perfect man you know
but like my short-term actions align
with those those long-term values and
the more you do that the more you like
yourself the less
the lesser criticism bothers you really
because you're just i'm tethered to it
right
yeah yeah i realize that your opinion
doesn't matter
yeah i mean you specifically but also
that's the thing like what matters is
the truth right
and and so well that's really ultimately
what i'm trying to get i don't want to
bang my opinion up against yours and
then we're arguing over aesthetics or
or something that is on the edges of
what is the truth
but if we can get beyond the opinion
right and beyond sides it's one of the
most dangerous things we have now we've
created these sort of
bifurcated sides and it's you versus me
we're otherizing other people
and i prefer community community unites
around something tribes unite against
something and so i'd rather have a
community of people who united around
doing some meaning
that's actually why we same side of the
booth this entire thing to show how
unified we are that's
great two more questions so in a decade
of doing this is that about right yeah
do you have a time you were on a stage
you're on a podcast you're on a radio
show and you look back and think
oh i was wrong i've changed my mind on
this thing i thought i thought you were
going to ask me like when have i screwed
up like a talk or something or when you
have screwed up or talk or something go
ahead all right i'll talk about when i
screwed up a talk
you can talk about what what because
yeah certainly a lot of things have
changed
um it was our book launch for everything
that remains back in 2013.
we had this like media event our
publicist set up like all these major
networks to come out and like watch this
event and i forgot half my talk
it was miserable man on stage on stage
like the live talk it was supposed to be
like you know 20 minutes long i think it
was like nine minutes long
because i just blanked on like the
center part and i practice it i
literally just performed it into camera
like two hours before that event but
like all the pressure yeah oh it was so
embarrassing man i i don't think
i only think like maybe 20 of the crowd
was like wait what just happened he just
went from here to here
[Laughter]
but uh how long ago was that that was
2013 november 2013. does that haunt you
or you just remember it oh it just
it actually if anything it's just taught
me a lesson to like to really
practice like to really prepare yeah
yeah yeah
i learned early on maybe a couple years
in that decluttering doesn't work
and so i know that that's weird what is
that from the minimalist because
people often think of us and they think
about decluttering their house right
but that's really the problem like if i
give you a video with the
the 67 steps to declutter your closet is
that really going to help you
is that your problem you have a shortage
of decluttering tips
yeah of course everyone knows how to
declutter their classes the question
then is
why do we simplify our lives because if
once you understand the why
how to it takes care of itself or it's
it's a google search right it's
the the solutions become easy yeah and
so
it's easy to start out with tactics and
you have to reverse into the whys right
yeah yeah so we often start with the
question how might your life be better
with less
because that answer is going to be
different for everyone but if you
understand that
the decluttering thing that'll happen
that'll happen as a
natural result without the your own
volition or
willing it into being say that one more
time so if
if you understand the why you know how
might my life be better with less maybe
it's
you know my finances will be improved
maybe it's i'll just have a cleaner
house maybe it's that my relationships
will improve
less stress or less drama or less nights
with no sleep
yeah and so you have all these benefits
if you truly understand those
then yeah taking care of your house
cleaning that up it's going to be simple
taking care of that relationship that's
been messy here's the key though simple
is not easy
oh it's brutal it is and we confuse the
two we think they're synonyms
well it's just like uh how do you lose
weight diet and exercise right
all right cool man thanks yeah yeah all
right real simple trillion dollar
industry right
right how do you fix your mental health
have great relationships and eat right
move right
ta-da right yeah thanks man appreciate
that uh rapid fire here
um how do you do a minimalist wedding go
we did a whole podcast episode on this
okay i'll refer them out yeah there you
go
you can check out the minimalist podcast
episode on minimalist weddings it's like
we set this up
i should do this for a living guys that
was an amazing pitch
um all right as a minimalist can i still
go see if we have concerts and comedy
shows again can i still go
oh dude i love that's one of my favorite
parts about living in la i know it
you're my favorite
yeah man going going to the comedy store
i'm everybody's favorite one don't tell
him
he knows we're about to go on tour 20
cities so we
encourage people yes dude these are
awesome plugs i'm telling you dude i'm
gonna do this for a living
um what are two or three books that
profoundly impacted you
oh man uh the power now is really good
by eckhart tolle i don't agree with all
his
you know pokey stuff but the power now
is a great book uh
what about you anything by anthony
demelo so stop fixing yourself
all right yeah yeah uh that's his newest
book uh the way to love is
is a classic masterpiece everything is
spiritual it's a really good one or how
to love and yeah pretty much anything
rob bell
excellent we'll link to those in the
show notes here and then
so i live out in the country and we got
a barn
full of any thing you can imagine
and i looked at it this weekend i saw
the what the week was that we were
meeting
and i had a like a this has to stop now
and i looked at my little kids
and they are absorbing this as the norm
like they're just supposed to be stuff
falling on you every time you walk into
the garage
so this is not an uh like a thinly
veiled for the audience question this is
just for
uh your buddy john what's one or two or
three things
i can sit down my kids are actually at
camp this week so it's just me and my
wife
what's one or two or three things we can
sit down tonight and say
let's make this different start that
question yeah but i asked
and then how so how might your life be
better with less get really clear with
your wife because her answers are going
to be different from yours how might my
life be better with less
that's a why question disguised as a
how-to question by the way
and then beyond that that we have some
actual hell too so in the book we have
a lot of people use things we have 16
different rules for living with less
boundaries yeah they're really
boundaries you can set up in your own
life
and then maybe a great way to start is
the 30-day minimalism game you want to
talk about that yeah so
we came up with this game where you find
someone who wants to like declutter with
you maybe it's like you and your wife i
mean my wife and i do this some once
where uh we to play the game you start
on the first day of the month you each
get rid of one thing and then on the
second day of the month
two things and then on the third day of
the month three things and then on the
four okay so you get it yeah
fourth and so on what do you do on the
27th
27th thanks and that's you know it's
about day 20 where it really starts to
get
like really uncomfortable you're like oh
man i got to get rid of 20 things today
and tomorrow 21 things
so um it's it's a great it's a great
start because
you know if you make it through the
month you would have gotten rid of about
500 items and
you could even make it fun with like a
friendly bet or something you know
better foot massage with your wife or
whatever it is and the winner
ten thousand dollars josh still owes me
10 grand my wife won't touch my feet
they're disgusting man they're not great
my feet are not great um real quick
incredible book what do you want people
to know about this book
just the just the title like yeah i mean
it's all inside i love people use things
because the opposite never works it's a
relationship book but not in the
traditional
sense it starts with our relationship
with our stuff and it goes into these
other areas of life that we've broken
that we need to heal
in a way before we can heal our
relationship with people so
it's our relationship with stuff our
relationship with our values our
relationship with ourselves
the person we talk to the most is us
right so good man and a relationship
with money etc
um and so healing all seven of those
relationships
starting with the stuff to make room for
what's truly important
yeah i love so one of my pet peeves
is using machine analogies to describe
people
and you touched on it just that idea of
how do i fix my wife or how do i fix my
husband i just hate that language
i love the language of healing right
because that's a different it's it's a
similar metaphor but it's
very very different it's human yeah yeah
it's beautiful and it leaves a scar it
leaves a reminder and it comes back
strong
hey guys thank you so much for joining
us like for real for real this makes my
heart feel so good y'all are so kind
thanks for watching i'm so grateful hey
you don't even remember you probably
remember
like a year ago when i was just starting
this thing you came by and you were so
lovely and kind
and then a few weeks later on the
internets um uh
uh instagra i'm still learning how the
instagram worked but it was like uh a
friday five follow
okay i don't know but you sent people
and at the time i had like 11 followers
and at the end of the day i had like 22.
nice it was a 100 increase straight up
for the minimalist
heck yeah huge win but it made my my
heart feel good
the little things guys nice i'm so
grateful for all those are the best the
best
okay since we end every show let's just
end it again
by the way inside baseball um this is
the second time we've done an ending
because i blew it the first time
when we end every single show we've ever
done with
somebody with my favorite song of all
time but we got josh and ryan
here and then i forgot it and said we
had to do it again and so here we are
um kelly took a break in her uh
incredible drug use i put the needle
down for a minute so
wow you went dark i was just gonna let
you off with weed or something
this is a heroin deal but whatever
needles needles it is
uh all right favorite song of all time
oh favorite song of all time so favorite
lyrics are from the song from andy davis
called good life
andy davis yeah he's from nashville and
um
man so he's got this line that i think
perfectly sums up what we talk about
with this whole minimalism thing
he said we struggle to pay rent
because jeans are expensive
and how good is that yeah because we're
our priorities are always
how can i look good how can i impress
someone
else well i'll buy these genes even if
it means that i'm
i can't afford to pay my rent this month
just rhyme
jeans with means ins that's like inside
rapper baseball right there
dude on the song of the day
[Music]
joshua fields milburn dropping one line
say it again we struggle to pay rent
because jeans are expensive
that's it right here on the dr john
dolone show